>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THE UPDATE.
MEANWHILE, THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS ARE AROUND THE
CORNER.
18 DAYS FROM RIGHT NOW.
AND THE CENTRAL QUESTION
REMAINING ISN'T JUST WHO WILL
WIN CONGRESS.
WHETHER THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WILL REMAIN A LEGITIMATE
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION OR
BECOME SOMETHING ELSE
ENTIRELY.
ELEMENTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
COALITION ARE BECOMING
RADICAL.
SOME THREATEN VIOLENCE AND
OTHERS ADVOCATE VIOLENCE AND
SOME EVEN TAKE THE NEXT STEP
AND ENGAGE IN VIOLENCE.
EVEN THE LEADERS, DEEP IN
ESTABLISHMENT WITH THE MOST TO
LOSE ARE SAYING THINGS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNIMAGINABLE A
YEAR AGO.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS NANCY
PELOSI.
WATCH HER EXPLAIN THAT PEOPLE
WILL BE HURT IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
GOALS.
AND THAT'S OKAY.
WATCH.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE TOTAL
CLARITY ABOUT WHAT WE DO WHEN
IT COMES TO EVERYTHING.
A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
IMMIGRATION.
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT GUN SAFETY.
WHETHER IT'S ABOUT CLIMATE.
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE AND IF
THERE IS SOME COLLATERAL
DAMAGE OR SOME OTHERS WHO DO
NOT SHARE OUR VIEW, WELL, SO
BE IT.
>> Tucker: "COLLATERAL
DAMAGE."
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT YOU.
YOU ARE COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN
PELOSI'S DIRECT CALCULATION.
THANK YOU FOR TELLING US.
YOU ARE A PERSON IN WAY,
INCONVENIENCE AND WILL BE
CRUSHED UNDER THE WHEEL OF
PROCESS.
ONE OF THE INFAMOUS EGGS BROKE
ON THE MAKE THE WORLD'S
GREATEST OMELETTE.
TODAY, A NEW YORK MAN CHARGED
WITH SENATORS WITH DEATH.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY DARED TO SUPPORT
THE CALVING CAVILING CAVILING
NOMINATION.
THEY -- SUPPORT THE BRETT
KAVANAUGH NOMINATION.
THIS WOMAN WAS IN THE WAY AND
MADE A MISTAKE TO WEAR NYPD
HAT IN THE PRESENCE OF A
LEFTIST.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WHY ARE YOU TRYING TO BLOCK
ME?
I'M JUST TRYING TO WALK HERE.
>> IT'S A TRAFFIC SIGNAL.
>> YOU'RE A [bleep]
IDIOT.
>> [bleep]
>> I'M NOT GOING TO TOUCH YOU.
I'M NOT LIKE YOUR HUSBAND.
I AM NOT GOING TO PUNCH YOU.
>> I'M NOT MARRIED.
>> I'M NOT LIKE YOUR BOYFRIEND
WHO IS GOING TO KNOCK YOU OUT.
>> MY HUSBAND DIED.
>> GOOD HER HIM.
GOOD.
NYPD SODOMIZING IMMIGRANTS
WITH THE BULLY STICKS.
SO, YEAH, YOUR HUSBAND CAN ROT
IN THE GRAVE.
>> Tucker: I'M GLAD YOUR
HUSBAND DIED IN 9/11 SAYS A
HUSBAND OF THE YOUTH WING OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ANN COULTER WATCHING MOMENTS
LIKE THESE AND WRITING ABOUT
IT.
THE NEW BOOK "RESISTANCE IS
FUTILE."
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
ANN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LOOK LIKE 19
DAYS FROM NOW?
HOW DO THEY PUT IT BACK
TOGETHER?
THEY SHOWED US WHO THEY ARE.
WHAT ARE THEY WHEN THE SMOKE
CLEARS?
>> I WOULDN'T JUDGE HOW THEY
DO THIS FALL BY -- ASSUME THE
COMMENTS ARE BELOVED BY THE
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO REMEMBER A BLUE
WAVE IS THE HISTORICAL NORM
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S POSSIBLE THEY TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
LUCKILY, BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU
SHOWED AND THE REACTION TO
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH DIDN'T LOOK
LIKE THEY WILL TAKE THE
U.S. SENATE.
THEY TAUGHT BE HAVING A HUGE
BLUE WAVE.
THEY PROBABLY WON'T HAVE IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE INSANE.
THEY HAVE GONE MAD.
>> Tucker: THOSE WHO RUN THE
PARTY INVEST IN IT.
THE PEOPLE WHO HOLD OFFICE OR
LIVELIHOOD DEPEND ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY MUST BE GETTING NERVOUS.
THEY CAN'T CONTROL THE BASE.
>> THEY DO THIS ALL THE TIME.
THEY DID IT AFTER FERRINGER.
TO HELP DEMOCRATS WIN AN
ELECTION.
THEY ARE WILLING TO GEN UP
RACE HATRED.
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED IN
FERGUSON, AT THIS POINT AFTER
KAVANAUGH AND CONTINUING UNTIL
THE ELECTION TO G GIN UP
WOMEN.
THEY CAN'T CONTROL THEM.
ONCE THEY HAVE DONE IT THEY
WALK AWAY.
YOU SEE THE FERGUSON EFFECT
WRITTEN ABOUT BY HEATHER
McDONALD AND OTHER.
THE RATES OF BLACK TEENS
MURDERED WENT UP
ASTRONOMICALLY AFTER FERGUSON
AND PARTICULARLY IN CITIES
WHERE THERE WAS AN ALLEGED
POLICERACE SHOOTING.
INCIDENTALLY -- POLICE RACIST
SHOOTING.
INCIDENTALLY I NOTICE THAT THE
POLICE STOPPED ATTACKING BLACK
PEOPLE WHEN THEY STARTED TO
WEAR BODY CAMERA.
DID YOU NOTICE IT WENT AWAY?
THE ACLU IS SUING SOME CITIES
TO MAKE THEM STOP WEARING BODY
CAMERAS BECAUSE THEY KEEP
GETTING CAUGHT MAKING FALSE
ALLEGATION OF A RACIST COP.
AS A PRINCETON WOMAN DID.
A PRISSTON PROFESSOR MADE --
PRINCETON PROFESSOR MADE
ALLEGATION OF RACIST STOP.
AH-HA!
BODY CAMERA.
COMPLETE LIE.
>> Tucker: DOES THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY EVER BECOME
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF 2012?
OR 1998?
OR A PARTY CONCERNED WITH THE
ECONOMICS AND SOMETHING OTHER
THAN IDENTITY POLITICS?
>> IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT.
THERE WAS AN INTERESTING
ARTICLE.
YOU WON'T HEAR THESE WORDS OUT
OF MY MOUTH OFTEN.
IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES" THIS
WEEK BY THOMAS EDSALL BREAKING
DOWN THE POLLS ON HOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS CHANGED.
I JUST NOTICED LOOKING AT IT,
LOOKING AT NANCY PELOSI.
WHITE LIBERAL WOMEN HAVE GONE
OFF THE CHARTS ON LEFT WING
CRAZENESS AND NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE ECONOMICS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS SOME
OF US NOTICE IN THE CLINTON
ERA.
THAT IS WHEN IT BEGAN IN THE
CLINTON ERA.
ABANDON THE WORKING CLASS.
IT'S PEDAL TO THE METAL ON THE
IDENTITY POLITICS AND THE